FEMALE SPEAKER: Ladies and
gentlemen, please welcome
senior vice president,
Vic Gundotra.
VIC GUNDOTRA: Well,
hello, everybody.
Hello.
On behalf of Google, let me
extend our warmest welcome to
all of you.
To the over 6,000 people here
at the Moscone Center in San
Francisco, welcome.
And to our Google I/O viewing
parties that are happening all
around the world, over 350
different parties with over
30,000 in attendance, welcome.
And finally, let me also welcome
the over 1 million
people who will be watching
this event
live stream on YouTube.
Welcome
to Google I/O. [APPLAUSE]
VIC GUNDOTRA: This is our fifth
year, and we're going to
make this Google I/O
incredibly special.
Our teams have worked very
hard to put on something
really great for you.
And we still have some
surprises left.
At the end of the day, however,
it's not just about
the hard work our
teams have done.
This conference is really
about you, developers.
When you think back over the
last five years, things like
Google Chrome or Android
were in their infancy.
We owe, in no small measure, the
success of our efforts due
to your support.
Thank you.
Thank you for betting with
Google, and thank you for
supporting us.
Thank you for spending three
days of your life here at the
Google I/O conference.
We hope you're going to
absolutely love it.
Now one small favor
to ask, please.
If you have a hot spot, please
turn the hot spot off, as it's
going to greatly increase our
chances of having a successful
set of demos.
With that, let's get
this started.
Please join me in welcoming
director of Android product
management, Hugo Barra.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGO BARRA: All right.
Good morning, everyone.
And welcome to the Android
keynote at I/O 2012.
Last year on this stage,
we talked about
momentum, mobile, and more.
Momentum, accelerating of
Android across the world.
Mobile, everything we're
doing to innovate on
smartphones and tablets.
And more, extending the Android
ecosystem well beyond
the typical mobile device.
This year, we're continuing with
the same three themes and
picking up right where
we left off.
Let's start with momentum.
Last year right here, we
announced that Android had
crossed the mark of 100
million devices.
100 million was a huge milestone
for us back then.
It's been a pretty busy year,
and I'm thrilled to announce
our latest milestone.
Ready?
400 million Android devices.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGO BARRA: 400 million is a
pretty huge number, but we're
definitely not slowing down.
Last year right here, we
announced that we were seeing
400,000 new Android devices
activated every day.
Well, today, 1 million new
Android devices are activated
every single day.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGO BARRA: That's about 12
new Android devices every
second of every day.
[CHEERS]
HUGO BARRA: Thank you.
More devices in the hands of
more people in a truly global
phenomenon.
Take a look at this chart.
What you see here is a heat
map representation of the
growth in Android devices
throughout the world
over the last year.
Places like Japan, South Korea,
and France grew between
200% and 300% in these
12 months.
But what's even more impressive
is that the
developing world is adopting
Android at
an even faster pace.
Very large markets, like Brazil,
India, Thailand, and
Indonesia, all grew around 500%
over the last year alone.
Really, really exciting.
And we're continuing to build
and innovate just as fast in
the Android team.
Today, we want to share with you
what we've been working on
since we launched Ice Cream
Sandwich late last year.
I'd like to introduce you
to our newest release.
You guys ready for this?
[CHEERS]
HUGO BARRA: Android
4.1 Jelly Bean.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGO BARRA: Jelly Bean builds
upon what we created with Ice
Cream Sandwich.
We want things to be simple,
beautiful, and really smart.
There are a few things
about Jelly Bean we
wanted to cover today.
Project Butter, a
performance-focused effort
that went deep into the
guts of the platform.
We'll then talk to you about
a number of delightful
improvements that we've made
throughout the entire system.
And finally, we'll show you
the new Google Search
experience on Android.
[CHEERS]
HUGO BARRA: Thank you.
To tell you about Project
Butter, please welcome Android
engineering director,
Dave Burke.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVE BURKE: Thanks, Hugo.
Our brain's visual cortex is
especially sensitive to the
physics of motion.
It notices delays of as little
as 10 milliseconds.
So with Jelly Bean, we put a lot
of effort into making the
user interface fast,
fluid, and smooth.
This is the project that
we call Project Butter.
The first thing we did was
improve the system frame rate
and make it consistent.
We took the display refresh
signal, called vSync, and
extended it to drive the entire
Android framework at 60
frames per second.
That's one heartbeat about
every 16 milliseconds.
And now everything runs in
lockstep, application
rendering, touchscreen
processing, screen
composition, and display
refresh.
In Jelly Bean, we also
introduced triple buffering in
the graphics pipeline.
And this allows the GPU, the
CPU, and display to all run in
parallel without waiting
on each other.
The result is a more consistent
rendering
framework, and everything
feels a lot smoother.
Scrolling, paging, animations,
they're all buttery smooth.
Next, we focused on improving
touch experience by solving
two problems.
The first problem is that touch
events are reported
independently of
screen update.
In Jelly Bean, we now actually
anticipate where your finger
will be at the time of screen
refresh and use that position
to draw the display.
This results in a more
reactive and
uniform touch response.
The second problem relates to
how devices conserve power.
They actually dial the CPU back
to a lower frequency when
there's not much activity in
the system, and if you
interact with the system in that
state, it can potentially
take 10s of milliseconds
for the CPU
to ramp up and respond.
And this can lead to
a sluggish UI.
So in Jelly Bean, we introduced
the concept of
Touch Input Boost.
Now when you interact with the
screen, we'll instantly ramp
the CPU up.
It's literally putting the full
power of the CPU at your
fingertips.
Now, one of our goals when we
started to work in Jelly Bean
was to be able to measure
and improve interactive
performance in a
scientific way.
So we created a new tool
called systrace.
And systrace collects data
directly from the Linux kernel
and uses that to produce an
overall picture of what the
system is doing.
The data's represented as a
group of vertically stacked
time series graphs.
And in this particular
application example, you can
see that there's a rendering
interruption that's much
longer than 16 milliseconds.
And this results in
dropped frames.
When you look at the data, it's
pretty easy to correlate
that with the database
interruption here.
So you know what to fix.
Systrace comes with the
Jelly Bean SDK.
And it's a really useful tool
for device manufacturers and
for you guys to optimize
the performance of your
application.
So how noticeable are these
changes in practice?
Well, we got out a high-speed
camera to compare a stock
device running Ice Cream
Sandwich against a device
running the latest Jelly Bean.
Let's take a look.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
DAVE BURKE: So this is a really
sophisticated camera
capable of capturing 4 million
pixels at a rate of up to 300
frames per second.
Device on the left is running
Ice Cream Sandwich.
Device on the right,
Jelly Bean.
So let's take a look at the
launcher animation.
So the Jelly Bean device has
a much higher frame rate.
It feels a lot smoother.
Let's take a look at
another example.
Let's look at the Quick
Contacts animation.
And again, the Jelly Bean
device on the right, it
animates much more smoothly and
much more consistently.
And it just feels much more
silkily smooth, and that's the
triple buffering and
vSync in action.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
DAVE BURKE: So these
improvements apply across the
whole system, and they apply
to all applications.
And it's something that we're
going to continue to improve
on in future Android releases.
If you want to learn more about
this, we've got a really
good session tomorrow called
For Butter or Worse.
And to butter you up even
further, let me
pass you back to Hugo.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGO BARRA: Thanks, Dave.
Well, Jelly Bean is not only
the fastest and smoothest
version of Android yet, but
we've also made a ton of
improvements throughout.
We've touched every corner of
Android, and it all comes
together in a way that's
really delightful.
So let's jump right in.
I have Randall here from the
Android product team to help
me with demos.
And first of all, people spend
a lot of time on the home
screen in Android because we've
always let you customize
it the way you want with
apps and widgets.
But when you've got a lot of
stuff on your home screen,
adding another widget or getting
things to fit just
right can be a little
bit difficult.
So we solved that problem
in Jelly Bean.
Let's go to the device.
So here's a home screen
with a bunch of apps.
Now, Randall is going to pick up
a widget from another home
screen and move it
to this one.
Now watch what happens.
Everything gets out of the way
and aligns perfectly around
the widget.
But what if the widget is too
big, and there isn't enough
room for it on the
home screen?
Well, here's another
home screen that
has even more apps.
Watch what happens now when
Randall moves that widget to
this screen.
It magically re-sizes
on its own.
And if you want to do some
spring cleaning in Jelly Bean,
you can just pick up a widget
and toss it off with a
familiar gesture.
You can do the same thing with
apps, as many as you want.
That's probably enough,
Randall.
Thanks.
Let's go back to slides.
So we also made text input on
Android a whole lot better.
In Jelly Bean, we refined and
retuned our dictionaries.
They're much more accurate,
more relevant.
And the keyboard learns
intelligently over time.
We've also added a bigram
prediction algorithm which
guesses the next word you're
going to type before you
start typing it.
It's really cool stuff.
But sometimes your hands aren't
free to type, which is
why Android supports
voice typing.
Now, while voice typing works
really well when you have a
data connection, if you don't
have one, it doesn't work.
And it can actually be slow if
you have a bad connection.
So in Jelly Bean, we shrunk the
Google Speech Recognizer
that runs in our data centers--
[APPLAUSE]
HUGO BARRA: We shrunk the Google
Speech Recognizer to
fit on the device itself.
So if you have a poor connection
or if you're
offline, you can still
type with your voice.
Why don't we go to the device?
Let's show you that live.
So Randall's going to put his
phone in airplane mode, and
he's going to use his voice
to write an email.
Now watch what happens.
And do listen carefully, because
this is one of the few
times when we let him speak.
RANDALL: This is a
demonstration of
voice typing, period.
Words appear even though
I don't have
a connection, period.
HUGO BARRA: There you go.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGO BARRA: All right.
Let's go back to the slides.
We're launching offline voice
typing initially for US
English, and we're
going to add more
languages pretty soon.
Now, we also wanted to make sure
that Android works well
for everyone, particularly given
how quickly Android is
growing around the world, like
I showed you earlier.
So in Jelly Bean-- if
we could go back a
couple slides, please.
So in Jelly Bean, we've improved
support for Arabic
and Hebrew.
We've added a new Arabic font
to the platform, and we're
also adding 18 new input
languages, including Persian,
Hindi, and Thai.
Let's go to the next
slide now.
There you go.
Making sure Android works for
everyone also means improving
accessibility.
With Jelly Bean, we're
introducing gesture mode,
which enables blind users to
reliably navigate the UI using
touch and swipe gestures in
combination with speech output.
It's really, really awesome.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGO BARRA: Thank you.
We've also added platform
support for external Braille
input and output devices
via Bluetooth.
And if you want to learn more
about accessibility on an
Android, stop by the Sandbox
just outside to see some
awesome Android devices with
integrated Braille support.
So that's accessibility.
Now let's talk about camera.
Well, Ice Cream Sandwich made
it possible to snap photos
really quickly.
The Jelly Bean camera app makes
it possible to review
photos you've already
taken really,
really quickly as well.
Let's show that live.
Let's go to the device.
So Randall is snapping
some photos here.
And you'll notice that there's
a new animation of the photo
flying out to the right.
So that tells you with a simple
wipe, you can bring it
back into view and look at
the photo you just took.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGO BARRA: Thank you.
From here, you can tap and share
this photo, as you know,
or you can keep swiping
to look at the
other photos you took.
If you want to go through these
photos really quickly,
just pinch to go to
Film Strip view.
And then you can scroll
much faster from here.
And if you don't like a photo,
you can easily get rid of it
by just swiping it away.
Pretty cool, right?
And if you delete a photo by
accident, you can always tap
Undo and bring it right back.
So that's camera.
Pretty cool.
In Ice Cream Sandwich, we
introduced Android Beam, which
lets you share things like web
pages, contacts, maps, and so
on between devices using NFC by
just tapping them together.
Today, more than a million
NFC-enabled Android devices
are shipping every
single week.
And that number is
growing quickly.
In Jelly Bean, we're introducing
two new Android
Beam features.
First, you can send someone a
photo or video by just tapping
your phones together.
And second, you can instantly
pair and connect your phone
with an NFC-enabled Bluetooth
device, like a speaker or a
headset, by just tapping
it with your phone.
It takes one second.
Absolutely brilliant.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGO BARRA: Let's keep going.
Thank you.
One of the signature features
of Android is notifications.
Android notifications
are great.
They show you what's important,
they never get in
your way, and they're accessible
from anywhere.
In Jelly Bean, notifications
show you more information.
They're actionable.
They expand and collapse.
They have full-bleed photos.
They're beautiful, and
they're customizable.
So you guys can build amazing
notifications into your apps.
I really want to
show you this.
Let's go to the device.
So here at the top, there's a
missed call from Hiroshi.
Rather than opening the phone
app and calling him back, you
can do that right from the
notification itself.
Just tap on Call Back.
It's really quick and easy.
Now, if you leave the phone app
while you're in this call,
when you're done, you can just
go back to Notifications and
hang up straight from there.
It's awesome.
Now the Gmail notification
moves up and
automatically expands.
You no longer need to open the
Gmail app at all to see what's
going on in your inbox.
It's all right there.
Nothing important right now, so,
Randall, why don't we just
swipe that away?
Now here's a calendar
notification.
And you can see that there's
a meeting here at 10:30.
Now, if you're running late or
you can't make it to the
meeting, you can easily email
everyone in the meeting and
let them know.
Just type in Email Guests.
And because you'll usually be in
a rush when you do this, we
give you a set of canned
responses.
You can choose any of these, or
of course, write your own.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGO BARRA: Thank you.
Let's go back to
Notifications.
So we can see that Romain shared
a photo on Google+.
Now you can actually see the
full-bleed photo right here in
Notifications.
And you can +1 it or even
share it right into your
circles all without
opening the app.
Here is a notification
from Foursquare.
You can quickly like or
comment on a friend's
check-in, again, without
having to open the app.
There's this TuneIn Radio.
It's a great Android app for
listening to radio stations
from around the world.
When I have a song playing and I
can see this beautiful album
art, I can control my music.
And I can actually quickly
favorite a song from here
without opening the app.
Now let me also show
you a quick trick.
Notifications expand on their
own as they bubble up to the
top, as you've been
seeing so far.
But you can also make them
expand or collapse whenever
you want with a simple
two-finger gesture.
Watch this.
In the expanded Pulse news
notification here, I can see
news stories complete with
photos and headlines.
Really, really powerful stuff.
So those are Jelly Bean
notifications.
They expand, and they collapse
when you need them.
They're actionable, and they
can show you a ton of new
information.
And just like in Ice Cream
Sandwich, you can dismiss all
notifications at once
with one simple tap.
Android makes your
life easier.
Simple tasks should never
require complex procedures.
Now let's talk about search.
From the very beginning,
Android had
search at its core.
With Jelly Bean, we took a
hard look at search and
redesigned it from
the ground up.
First, a new UI.
Second, faster and more
natural voice search.
And third, a new feature we're
calling Google Now.
Let's start with the new UI.
Last month, we introduced
the knowledge
graph in Google search.
The goal is for Google to
understand that the words you
use when you're searching are
not just words, but real
things in the real world.
In Jelly Bean, we're using the
power of the knowledge graph
to show you search results
in a new, richer way.
For example, if you want to
know what movies Angelina
Jolie has starred in, we'll
show this card.
Or if you ask how much the Earth
weighs, you'll see an
answer like this.
If you're searching for the
weather in New York, we'll
show you a card with the
weekly forecast.
If you want to find a nearby
Starbucks, we'll show you a
card with a quick map of some
stores close to you and a
shortcut to take you
to Google Maps.
Now let's show you what we've
done with Voice Search.
Sometimes you'd rather just
speak your search query or ask
a question.
In Jelly Bean, voice search
is much faster.
It's also better at
understanding natural language.
And it speaks answers back to
you using the power of the
knowledge graph.
Let's go to the device and
show you this live.
Randall, why don't you show
us a few more examples.
You can talk.
RANDALL: I'm gonna ask
a few questions,
and Google will respond.
Who is the prime minister
of Japan?
[ELECTRONIC BEEP]
FEMALE SPEAKER: The prime
minister of Japan
is Yoshihiko Noda.
HUGO BARRA: Try a few more.
RANDALL: We'll try
another one.
What is the definition
of robot?
[ELECTRONIC BEEP]
FEMALE SPEAKER: Robot.
A machine capable of carrying
out a complex series of
actions automatically.
RANDALL: That's pretty
appropriate.
Try another.
How tall is the Space Needle?
[ELECTRONIC BEEP]
FEMALE SPEAKER: Space Needle
is 604 feet tall.
RANDALL: We'll give
it one more try.
Show me pictures of
pygmy marmosets.
[ELECTRONIC BEEP]
HUGO BARRA: That's great.
Now notice that if you go back
to the results, if you swipe
away that card, there's
a wealth of additional
information from the web on
pygmy marmosets, which, as I'm
sure you know, are the smallest
monkeys in the world.
Google will always give you web
search results for all of
your questions.
Thanks, Randall.
Let's go back to slides.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGO BARRA: Thank you.
Now, the third part of the new
Android search experience is
called Google Now.
Today's smartphones
are powerful.
They can do pretty much
anything you ask.
Search the web, give
you directions,
traffic info, anything.
But smartphones are only as
smart as you tell them to be.
They rely on you to
do everything.
You have to enter a search
query, you have to type in a
street address, and you have
to ask for traffic in a
particular area.
But with Google Now, that
starts to change.
Google Now gets you just the
right information at just the
right time.
And all of it happens
automatically.
So how do we do this?
If you choose to, Google Now
uses things like your search
history, your location history,
and your calendar to
figure out what information
you might need and when.
Let's see a few examples
on slides.
Traffic.
Google Now figures out
when you commute from
home to work and back.
It'll then tell you how long
the commute on your usual
route is going to be.
And it'll give you
a faster route if
there's a lot of traffic.
Next, public transit.
When you're near a bus stop or
on a platform at a subway
station, Google Now tells you
when the next bus or train
will arrive.
Places.
Google Now will show you bars,
restaurants, and places of
interest around you as you
walk down the street.
And when you're in a restaurant
trying to figure
out what to order, Google Now
will tell you what that
restaurant is best known for.
Next, appointment.
When you have a calendar event,
Google Now will help
you get there on time.
For example, if you normally
take the bus to get around,
Google Now will tell you when
to leave based on how long
it'll take you to walk to the
bus stop, when the next bus
arrives, and how long that bus
ride will take, so you get
there on time.
Flights.
If you have an upcoming flight
that you've searched for,
Google Now keeps you up
to date on the status.
It tells you which terminal to
go to, and it updates you if
there's a delay, all
automatically.
Sports.
Google Now keeps you updated on
your favorite sports teams
in real time.
You'll see scores and
upcoming games.
And the best part is you
don't need to set up
your favorite teams.
You've already done that by
searching for them on Google.
Travel.
Google Now knows when
you're traveling.
And if you're traveling
internationally, Google Now
will give you interactive cards
for currency conversion
and translation.
It also conveniently tells you
what time it is back home.
And there's tons more.
I'd like to welcome on
stage [? Barish ?]
[INAUDIBLE], Google Now
product manager.
[? Barish ?] is going to show
you how Google Now helps him
navigate his day.
[? Barish. ?]
[? BARISH: Thank you, ?]
Hugo.
Hi, everyone.
I'm really excited to show
you how Google Now
can work for me.
So let's get started.
The easiest way to get
to Google Now--
there are two ways.
You can either tap on the Search
box, or you can simply
swipe up from the bottom
of the screen.
And when you do that,
you see the familiar
Google search box.
You also see a beautiful header
that changes based on
your time and location.
You also see the Google
Now cards beneath it.
So let's start with
the first one.
Google Now is telling
me that I have a
meeting at 10:30 AM today.
It's also telling me that this
meeting is 16 minutes away
from where I am.
Google Now also notifies me when
it's time to leave, so
I'm not late for my meeting.
Here, it tells me that I
need to leave by 10:14.
Google Now knows that
I'm a Giants fan.
And right now, it's telling me
that there's a Giants game
coming up in a few hours.
And this card is going to keep
me updated with the scores,
and I know what's happening
in real time.
If I wanted to, I can buy
tickets from here real easily.
Let's think about when you
want to figure out a
place to get lunch.
Google Now knows that I'm not
here too often, and I don't
know the area too well.
So it's showing me a few places
nearby, including some
restaurants.
Let's take a look.
Zero Zero looks pretty good, so
I'm going to tap on it and
get more details.
This takes me to Google Maps.
And from here, I can get a
wealth of information.
I could also book a
table if I wanted.
Let's go back.
And Google Now has also figured
out that I go to the
gym usually around lunch time.
And it's telling me that the
gym is 29 minutes away.
So I want to get a work
out, but I was
going to take a flight.
And it looks like my
flight is delayed.
So I have enough time
to actually go and
squeeze in a work out.
Google Now is also telling me
that my flight is delayed, and
I'm only 19 minutes away
from the airport.
It's also telling me that when
I get to the airport, I'm
going to go to terminal two.
That's a quick demo
of what Google Now
can do for me today.
Your cards will get
smarter and more
accurate as you use them.
And we're just beginning.
We'll be adding more
cards over time.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGO BARRA: Thanks,
[? Barish. ?]
That was great.
So that was an overview of
Jelly Bean for you guys.
Project Butter, a bunch of
delightful improvements like
easier home screen organization,
offline voice
typing, a new camera app,
and awesome expandable
notifications.
Lastly, you got a preview
of the new Google search
experience on Android.
Can't wait for you guys
to actually try that.
Now I'm sure you all want to
know when you can get your
hands on Jelly Bean.
We're going to roll out over
the air updates to Galaxy
Nexus, Motorola Xoom, and Nexus
S and also release Jelly
Bean to open source starting
in mid-July.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGO BARRA: Thank you.
But we're making the SDK
available to you today as a
developer preview.
You can download it right now
from developer.androi
d.com/jellybeans
dkdeveloperpreview.
The SDK is built for you guys,
Android app developers.
But as you know, chipset
vendors and device
manufacturers develop for
Android too, to bring us their
awesome hardware.
So today, we're announcing the
Android Platform Development
Kit, or PDK for short, which
is like the SDK, but for
Android hardware developers.
It contains the necessary source
code and low-level API
documentation required to port
Android to your hardware if
you are a hardware developer.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGO BARRA: Thank you.
PDK will be available to Android
device partners two to
three months before the platform
release date of all
future Android versions.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGO BARRA: Thanks.
And we've actually started
with this release.
A beta version of the Jelly
Bean PDK has already been
available to a few partners for
the last few weeks, and
they've been providing
us valuable feedback.
We've incorporated that
feedback, and now it's
available to everyone
on an ongoing basis.
PDK enables Android OEMs and
chipset makers to innovate in
parallel with Google and ensure
the latest Android
release can be well optimized
for their hardware.
So that's what we're doing
on the platform side.
To tell you about what we've
been doing on Google Play,
here's Android engineering
director, Chris Yerga, fresh
out of the salon.
CHRIS YERGA: Thank you, Hugo.
Those hair jokes
never get old.
So this past March, we announced
Google Play, your
digital entertainment
destination not just for apps
and games, but also for movies,
music, and books.
Google Play is entirely
cloud-based, which means that
all of your content is
always available
across all of your devices.
And Google Play is Android
apps, lots of apps.
Today, there are more than
600,000 apps and games in
Google Play.
And we're seeing more than
1.5 billion installs
every single month.
And we've just reached a total
of 20 billion app installs
across Google Play.
It's incredible.
It's billion with a B. And
there's no way we could have
done that without the support
of everybody in this room.
Developers are the lifeblood
of our ecosystem.
So thanks for all your hard work
and support in achieving
this amazing milestone.
Now, over the past year, we've
launched a number of features
to support you as developers
and help
you build your business.
Android apps are available
in 190
countries across the globe.
And paid apps are available
in 132 of those countries.
You have flexible ways to
monetize your apps.
You could use an ad-supported
model, paid applications, an
in-app billing, which you have
embraced very successfully.
Just a year after the launch of
in-app billing, more than
50% of our apps revenue now
comes from in-app billing.
And so we wanted to keep
that momentum going.
With the recent launch of
subscription billing for
applications, we now enable you
even more ways to monetize
your Android apps
in Google Play.
We're also giving users more
ways to pay for your apps.
We've expanded carrier billing
to a dozen additional carriers
across five different
countries.
And we're continuing
that momentum
by adding new partners.
We've also given you insight
into your business with
additional metrics in the Google
Play Developer Console,
easier ways to distribute your
apps with APK expansion files,
and ways to connect with
users with the
ability to reply to reviews.
And for aspiring new developers
out there, we've
launched Android Training, a
collection of free online
classes to help you learn
best practices.
And today, we're announcing
several new features for
developers as part
of Google Play.
So first, we know that you spend
a lot of time and money
writing great apps.
And so we're constantly at
work trying to help you
protect your investments.
We're introducing app encryption
in Jelly Bean.
From Jelly Bean forward--
[LIGHT APPLAUSE]
CHRIS YERGA: That's fine.
You can love it.
Come on.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRIS YERGA: From Jelly Bean
forward, paid apps in Google
Play are encrypted with a
device-specific key both
before they're delivered
to the device and
stored on the device.
We're also announcing
smart app updates.
So today when you update an
app, your users have to
download the entire APK again.
Clearly, this wastes bandwidth
and battery life, and we can
do better than that.
With smart app updates, users
will only download the parts
of the APK that have changed.
We looked at some of the most--
[APPLAUSE]
CHRIS YERGA: I've read through
this stuff so many times, I
don't know what parts are going
to be exciting to you.
But the team is very excited
about this as well.
And on average across the most
popular apps we looked at, a
smart APK update is
about a third the
size of a full update.
So it's going to be much easier
for you to have your
users on the latest version.
It's a win for carriers,
developers, and users.
And the best news about
it is we handle it
automatically for you.
You don't need to do anything.
And it's supported on
Gingerbread and above.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRIS YERGA: So for a couple
years now, we've offered
developers a service we call
Android Cloud To Device
Messaging, which lets you send
data to apps while they're
running in the background
without having to implement
your own sync solution.
It's been amazingly successful
with the developer community.
We deliver billions of C2DM
messages every single day.
Now we're ready to take C2DM
to the next level.
And we're announcing Google
Cloud Messaging, which adds
great new features like message
multicasting, message
payloads, and more.
But I think the best feature--
hopefully, you all agree--
is that Google Cloud Messaging
is completely free for all
developers, and there are
no quota limitations.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRIS YERGA: If you want to
learn more, we're going to
have a special session
on this tomorrow on
Google Cloud Messaging.
I would urge you to attend.
So lots of exciting developer
announcements.
But Google Play is also about
great digital content, movies,
music, and books.
Google Play has thousands
of movies to rent.
You can watch new releases,
blockbuster films, and your
favorite classics on your
Android phone, tablet, or even
on the web.
Google Play also has millions
of songs from your favorite
artists, whether it's an indie
band, rock legend, hip hop
stars, and everyone
in between.
And you can also bring all the
songs you already own to
Google Play and store up to
20,000 of them for free in our
music library.
So you could listen to them
anywhere as well.
And finally, Google Play is also
the world's largest ebook
collection with more than 4
million titles available.
And all of this content is
stored in the cloud, so it's
available whenever you want,
wherever you are.
And today, we're bringing more
content to Google Play.
It starts with movie
purchasing.
Now along with rentals, your
favorite movies are available
for sale on Google Play, which
means that they'll be yours to
watch as many times
as you like.
And we're also adding TV to
the video experience.
You'll be able to purchase
episodes or entire seasons of
your favorite TV shows.
It's perfect for when you have
a spare half hour, or you're
on the bus or something.
And it really works well
with a mobile device.
All of this is launching
today on Google Play.
And we've partnered with some
of the biggest names in the
entertainment industry,
including Disney, ABC Studios,
NBC Universal, Sony Pictures,
and Paramount.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRIS YERGA: Finally,
magazines are
coming to Google Play.
We've partnered with top
magazine publishers, including
Hearst, Conde Nast, and
Meredith, so you can enjoy
hundreds of titles right from
your Android phone or tablet.
This includes premium magazines,
like Esquire,
Wired, and Family Circle.
Buy single issues
or subscription.
And we offer 14-day free trials
on our most popular
magazines to encourage
you to try it out.
We've got all this great content
on Google Play, music,
movies, books, and now TV
and magazines as well.
You can enjoy it anywhere, on
your phone, on the web, or on
your tablet.
And speaking of tablets,
I think Hugo has a
few words to share.
HUGO BARRA: Thanks, Chris.
Well, it's always been a goal
of the Nexus program to
provide you with the best of
Google experience, access to
the latest software coupled with
an Android experience the
way that Google envisions it.
We wanted to take that model
one step further.
We wanted to design a best of
Google experience that is
optimized around all this great
content available in
Google Play.
We wanted a device that lets you
immerse yourself in all of
that media.
We wanted you to be delighted
when you read books,
magazines, watch movies,
and play games.
So we partnered with a great
company, ASUS, to help us
build just that device.
And today, we're introducing
Nexus 7.
It's a beautiful
7-inch tablet.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGO BARRA: Thank you.
It's built for Google Play.
It's running Android
4.1 Jelly Bean.
And here it is.
Nexus 7.
And by the way, we're really
pleased to have Jonney Shih,
the chairman of ASUS, here
in the audience today.
Jonney, please stand up.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGO BARRA: Thank you.
So let me tell you a
bit about Nexus 7.
It's super thin, light,
and portable.
And yet, we've managed to pack
a lot into this device.
First of all, the display.
1280 by 800 HD display, which
is perfect for reading and
watching videos in
stunning clarity.
Performance.
Tegra 3 chipset with
a quad-core CPU.
And--
[APPLAUSE]
HUGO BARRA: Wait,
there's more.
So Tegra 3 chipset with
a quad-core CPU
and a 12-core GPU.
That's basically 16 cores,
which makes everything,
including games, extremely
fast and smooth.
Front-facing camera,
perfect for Google+
Hangouts and video chatting.
All the connectivity options
you'd expect, Wi-Fi,
Bluetooth, and NFC.
Gyroscope and accelerometer,
essential for
high performance gaming.
And battery, up to nine hours
of video playback and up to
300 hours stand-by time.
And best of all, it's only 340
grams, just about the weight
of an average paper book.
It fits perfectly in one hand.
You can put it in a
purse or a bag.
It doesn't tip over when you're
reading or watching a
movie in bed.
It just feels right.
That's Nexus 7.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGO BARRA: Music,
movies, books,
magazines, apps, and games.
All the great content from
Google Play right at your
fingertips.
Now to show you Nexus 7 in
action, here's Chris Yerga
once again.
CHRIS YERGA: Thanks, Hugo.
We designed the Nexus
7 experience with
three goals in mind.
Create the best possible Google
Play experience, make
all your favorite Google apps
work beautifully, and support
the next generation
of apps and games.
Nexus 7 is made for
Google Play.
When you power it on, your
content is front and center.
Right here on the home screen is
my library, containing the
content I've recently been
reading, listening to, or
watching on any of my devices.
So earlier, I was reading The
Bourne Dominion on my phone.
So we can tap on the cover
there and pick up exactly
where I left off on
that other device.
Nexus 7 is an ideal device
for reading books.
The form factor and the
weight are just right.
It has the portability of
a paperback backed by a
cloud-powered personal
library of books.
Now I'd like to show
you the magazine
experience on Nexus 7.
Here's the new Google
Play magazines app.
And just like your
coffee table, the
newest stuff is on top.
You can swipe through and
find something that's
interesting to read.
Why don't we go ahead and, uh--
Esquire.
Once I bring it up, I can tap
on it and bring up a list of
page thumbnails on the bottom to
quickly swipe through, find
an article that I'm interested
in reading.
So yeah, that one looks good.
And once we open it up, you
look at the content.
It just looks beautiful
on Nexus 7.
But if I want to focus maybe on
something that's a little
bit more of a pure reading
experience, I can tap on the
View Text link and get the
contents of the article in a
form that's optimized
for that.
Still looks beautiful
on Google Play.
From here, I can also navigate,
and bring up a table
of contents, and quickly pull
up any other article.
So now let's look at some
interactive features.
So why don't we go to
Shape magazine.
And here from the cover, since
this is an interactive title,
I can tap on any of the
interesting articles
there and get to a--
I think he wants to work on his
abs, so he's going to pick
the flat abs.
So we've gone beyond print
replica here and added
interactive elements to custom
fit the text to the device,
keeping everything readable
without impacting the design.
Randall can drag up to expand
the content right here on the
page, and even tap on the link
to jump into an exercise
routine, and get further details
on those all-important
ab exercises that Randall
likes to do, all without
leaving the page.
So that's our premium
magazine reading
experience on Google Play.
Nexus 7 is also ideal for
watching movies and TV
wherever you are, long plane
rides, road trips with the
family, or just sitting at home,
watching on the sofa.
So let's open the Google
Play movies and TV app.
And here you see all
of your movies.
We can swipe over
to see TV shows.
And you can get to your personal
videos as well.
So why don't we pick
something?
Astute observers will note
that I'm a Parks and
Recreation fan.
So why don't we tap on Episode
1 there and start
watching some TV?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Who are the suits?
-They want me to
run for office.
-Oh my god, Leslie, yay.
-I know, right?
Yay.
-Yay.
Wait, what does that mean
about you and Ben?
-I don't know.
I think it's going
to be really bad.
-Uh-oh.
Do you want to go back
to saying, yay?
-Yes, please.
-Yay.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
CHRIS YERGA: Video looks
stunning on Nexus 7.
You can see the individual
hairs on
Ron Swanson's mustache.
So in here, you have access to
the movies and episodes you
purchased and links to the store
for other episodes of
the season.
And you can, of course, also
download your TV shows for
offline use if you're going to
be somewhere without Wi-Fi,
like on a plane.
So that's finding content
I already have.
What about discovering
new content?
With Nexus 7, we're introducing
a powerful new
recommendations engine for
discovering content that's
relevant to you.
We present this information on
beautiful and dynamic widgets
on your home screen.
Here you can see that we've
set ours up for
recommendations for apps,
books, and movies.
But you can customize it to show
the content you're most
interested in.
And if you don't like a
particular recommendation,
just dismiss it, and
you'll get another.
These widgets are intelligent.
And they'll get smarter
and more accurate the
more you use them.
Now, sometimes new content
finds you.
Maybe you hear a song you like
on the radio or TV, but you
don't exactly know what it is.
We've added a "What's
this song?" widget.
You just tap on it, and it
will identify the music
playing and give you a link
to the Play Store.
So you can buy it instantly.
So the device is beautiful,
but let's go back to the
slides for a second.
Nexus 7 is the perfect device
to use all the Google
applications you already
know and love.
Gmail on Nexus 7.
It's a perfect size to read and
respond to your emails.
Chrome.
Your favorite websites look
beautiful on the HD display.
And this is the first device
that's ships with Chrome as
the standard browser.
Let's go back to the device
and take a look at some of
those apps.
Why don't we start
with YouTube?
So the new YouTube app has a
great tablet-optimized design.
You got your channel feed
here on the left.
And you can just swipe over.
Why don't we pick something
here to watch and get some
video going?
You've got high-def YouTube
right in the
palm of your hand.
It's the YouTube that you
already know and love, but
optimized for Nexus 7.
Now in addition to exploring a
huge amount of videos online,
you can also explore the
world around you.
So let's take a look
at Google Maps.
Now, in Google Maps, you can
find your way around with the
features you are already
familiar with, like
turn-by-turn navigation, public
transit, live traffic
in Street View.
But what about getting to know
a place before you get there?
I heard about a local bar called
District, so let's go
check it out.
We can tap here and get all this
great information about
the restaurant, including
Zagat reviews
from Google+ Local.
And I can also scroll down
and tap on See Inside.
Once I do, I'm inside the bar.
I've got this nice view.
And for an even better
experience, I can turn on
Compass mode.
So why don't you go ahead
and do that, Randall?
Now we've had this feature
for a little while.
But what we've done in the
latest version is hook it up
to the gyroscope, which makes
it incredibly smooth, and
fast, and very responsive.
It's just like being there.
Now, as we announced, we're
also adding support for
offline maps, so you can save
the data for an entire city
locally on the device and be
able to use maps without a
data connection.
Simply tap on the menu.
It's as easy as bringing up
the menu and tapping Make
Available Offline.
And you're good to go.
So those features are all in the
latest version of Google
Maps shipping with Nexus 7.
Now I want to talk to you
about Google Currents.
Currents brings you all the
great content that the web has
to offer in a mobile magazine
format that looks incredible
on Nexus 7.
My morning routine is, I open up
Currents first thing in the
morning every day to
check out the news.
Subscribe to a number
of feeds.
You have trending stories
here around the top.
But why don't we tap into The
Daily Beast and take a look at
what articles are there?
So here we have a list
of recent articles.
We can swipe through and read
in a reading mode that's
actually built on the same
technology that the magazines
web view is.
So it has that same
beautiful look.
And you can see the content here
is pulled straight from
the web and beautifully
formatted for Nexus 7.
Now, behind all of this
great content is
the power of Google.
So what we've done is
we baked Google
Translate right into Currents.
So we can go to the menu, and
I can translate everything
into another language.
And within a few seconds
of doing that--
Randall, I believe,
picked Arabic.
So we're going to see
this entire edition
translated into Arabic.
Currents is another Google app
that works great on Nexus 7.
With its quad-core CPU,
gyroscope, and accelerometer,
Nexus 7 is a serious
gaming device.
We'll start with the
game Horn from
Phosphor Games in Chicago.
Horn is an epic adventure, set
in a richly detailed world
with the kind of environment
never before
seen on a mobile device.
You've got lens flares,
environmental effects, and
even individually rendered
leaves on the trees.
So as Randall takes the express
elevator down here, we
can see that in addition
to the graphics looking
beautiful, the animation
is very fluid.
And it just controls
beautifully.
This is the kind of experience
that, until recently, you
would not have been able to
see anywhere out of a
dedicated gaming console.
So Horn is really putting all
those 12 GPU cores to work.
But of course, not everything
in Horn
is shiny and beautiful.
Let's cut there.
We don't want to ruin the
surprise, but it ends badly.
So going from alive to dead,
we're gonna take a look at
Dead Trigger from
Madfinger Games.
They're a developer
located in Prague.
Now, while for some games--
[LIGHT APPLAUSE]
CHRIS YERGA: All right, got my
Pragues over here, nice--
guns and zombies would be enough
of a selling point.
But Dead Trigger uses the
computational power of the
Nexus 7 to create everything
from-- you see these water
droplets that are refracting
and going
down here on the lens.
You've got realistic fogs
and, of course,
lots and lots of blood.
He was supposed to do a head
shot there, and he did it.
Give it up for Randall.
Nice job.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRIS YERGA: Who says mobile
gaming has to be casual?
So now that you've seen
everything Nexus 7 can do,
Hugo, I think we all have one
remaining question, which is
how can I get one?
HUGO BARRA: Thanks, Chris.
That was awesome.
So Nexus 7, built to bring you
the best of Google in a super
thin, light, and portable device
that's optimized for
Google Play.
It's a fantastic device that we
want to get into the hands
of as many people as we can.
That's why starting today, we're
making Nexus 7 available
starting at only $199.
And when you buy your Nexus 7,
we'll also give you a $25
credit to spend in the Google
Play Store, as well as some
great content to build
out your library.
You'll get the Transformers,
Dark of the Moon movie from
our friends at Paramount
Pictures, the book The Bourne
Dominion, and free magazine
issues of Popular Science,
Food Network, Conde Nast
Traveler, and others.
Starting today, you can order
Nexus 7 directly from Google
Play with orders shipping
in mid-July.
It's available in the US,
Canada, the UK, and Australia,
with more countries to follow.
Now, Android was always
meant to go
beyond phones and tablets.
Last year at I/O, we showed you
a sneak peak of a new kind
of Android media device which
we called Project Tungsten.
We've been really busy since
then, and now we want to show
you what we've created.
And to do that, please welcome
Joe Britt and Matt Hershenson.
JOE BRITT: Thank you, Hugo.
You just saw an amazing tablet
for enjoying all your great
Google Play content, but
we want to go further.
We're entering a new era in
consumer electronics where the
combination of hardware,
software, and the cloud is
opening up an entirely new
world of possibilities.
With Project Tungsten, we
brought together the power of
Android and Google Play to
develop the first consumer
electronics product Google has
ever designed and built from
the ground up.
We call it Nexus Q.
Let's take a look.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-I think most people have no
idea what it is when they
first look at it.
-We're trying to create
something that is unexpected.
-Powerful and--
-Mysterious.
-There was a point in time where
consumer electronics
were a physical thing, a
transistor radio, or a
cassette player, or a Walkman.
And then the software element of
it became very important in
terms of the experience.
And now I think we're entering
this era where consumer
electronics is the
hardware, and the
software, and the cloud.
-Q is a small, Android-powered
computer, and it connects to
all of the media that you have
stored in the cloud.
The fact that it was going to be
in your home meant that it
needed to be not only
functional, but also beautiful.
-Google products are used by
millions and millions of
people every day on the
web and mobile side.
How that translates into
physical products, it raises a
lot of interesting
opportunities.
-This is how you get the
software from the device to
your phone.
-Now that we're moving into
an era where devices are
controlled from your phone or
your tablet, we can allow
people to use their devices to
control their entertainment in
a very simple way.
-People's stereo systems, they
weren't very much revered.
But when you go around to
people's houses, you would
never touch them.
The idea here is that people can
be inquisitive, play with
it, but also start using
it interactively.
-And it's the sort of thing
that you think, why can't
everything do this?
Isn't this the right way
that music should be?
-This really is a third-wave of
consumer electronics, and
it's all about the cloud.
Nexus Q is just the beginning.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
JOE BRITT: Thank you.
We're really excited to unveil
Nexus Q. It's a small,
Android-powered computer
that's designed to
live in your home.
It plugs into the best speakers
and TV in your house,
and it's always connected
to the cloud.
Nexus Q tightly integrates with
Google Play, so you can
easily stream music and video.
You use your Android phone or
tablet to control it, but
you're not actually streaming
content from
your device to it.
Instead, Nexus Q pulls
your content
directly from Google Play.
So in other words, you use
your phone or tablet to
control the cloud.
Now, before I show you how this
works, Matt's going to
tell you about all the design
and engineering that went into
creating Nexus Q.
MATT HERSHENSON: Thanks, Joe.
When we started developing this
product, we wanted to
build something really
special, not just
another black box.
The industrial design
is totally unique.
And what we've managed to put
into this small sphere is
nothing short of incredible.
The heart of Nexus Q is an OMAP
4460 which is the same
chip used in Galaxy Nexus.
It also has a state of the
art, audiophile grade
amplifier built right in,
so you can hook your
speakers right up.
And at 25 watts, this small
sphere can really fill a room
with beautiful, clear,
crisp sound.
Of course, music and video
today are digital.
Some would say, analog outputs
are a little old-fashioned.
Nexus Q has optical digital
audio and micro-HDMI outputs,
so you can stream music and
1080p video to the best
speakers and the best
TV in your home.
Nexus Q has dual band Wi-Fi and
ethernet, as well as NFC
and Bluetooth which lets you
set it up in a few minutes
right from your phone.
There's also a micro USB port to
connect future accessories
and encourage general
hackability.
[APPLAUSE]
MATT HERSHENSON: Always
popular and
always a great feature.
The hardware is pretty cool,
but what brings Nexus Q to
life is Android.
Joe's gonna show us
what it can do.
JOE BRITT: Let's take a look
at Nexus Q in action.
So Matt made me move my living
room to the stage here today.
And I'm going to start by
playing some music for you.
So up here, let's go
to the device.
And we can see that this is
Randall's device, and he's
gone into the Google
Play music app.
Here we can see his entire
music collection.
We can see his play lists.
As he scrolls around, we can
also see his artists, albums,
and so on, all stored
in the cloud.
Now Randall is going to choose
a room to start playing music
in, and he's picking
the living room.
Let's see what music he picks.
And it looks like he
picked "The Need
Superficial" by Oddisee.
You have very good
taste, Randall.
And it's very appropriate
because building Q has been a
bit of an odyssey.
[MUSIC - "THE NEED SUPERFICIAL"
BY ODDISEE]
JOE BRITT: It sounds
really good.
And as you can hear, it
starts playing right
away from the cloud.
[MUSIC - "THE NEED SUPERFICIAL"
BY ODDISEE]
JOE BRITT: Now, we wanted the
experience of listening to
music to be more than just
great quality sound.
Part of what makes Nexus Q so
cool is that listening to
music can also be visual
and interactive.
It lights up with a ring of
LEDs around the perimeter
which respond to the
music as it plays.
And if you have it hooked up
to a TV, you'll see this
visualizer as well.
If you have more than one Nexus
Q, you can play music
throughout your entire house.
You just pick the rooms you
want, and it'll play your
music in sync.
Now for example, Randall's
going to
show us how this works.
He's going to add the green room
Nexus Q, so the rest of
the team back there can enjoy
the music in perfect sync with
the living room here on stage.
Mobile devices have made music
more of a personal and
sometimes isolating
experience.
But music is often best
enjoyed with friends.
That's why we made Nexus
Q the first ever
social streaming device.
It's a cloud-connected jukebox
where everyone brings their
own music to the party.
Your friends can just start
adding songs from their own
Google Play music libraries to
Nexus Q. Let me show you how
this works.
I'm going to ask Matt and my
friend, Chris, to help me out.
Where did Chris go?
Oh, here comes Chris.
Chris, please come on over, and
have a seat on the sofa.
So now Randall is going to start
playing another song
from his Nexus 7.
And once he does that, we
can see the music queue.
[MUSIC - "THE NEED SUPERFICIAL"
BY ODDISEE]
JOE BRITT: And-- oh, Randall
picked the same song.
So we've already heard
this song.
So let's give somebody else
a chance to play the DJ.
Matt, what would you
like to hear?
MATT HERSHENSON: Well, how
about this song "All the
Lights" by FAWN.
It reminds me of those cool
lights on Nexus Q.
JOE BRITT: Nice.
And so Matt is going to
use his device to add
a song to the queue.
And what we should see is that
song added to the queue.
And there it is.
Look.
So how about another
one, Matt?
MATT HERSHENSON: OK.
Pretty cool.
I'm gonna do some more.
How about this song "Dark
Star" by Polica?
JOE BRITT: That's a
really cool song.
So you can see that the songs
Matt just added appeared right
in the queue on Randall's
device.
So everybody who has a device
is able to see the queue of
music that's going
to be played.
Chris, what do you
have to add?
CHRIS: I think I'm going to
add this really great, new
rockabilly guitarist,
JD McPherson.
But I'm not interested in
waiting around, so I think I'm
just going to take right over.
[MUSIC - "NORTH SIDE GAL"
BY JD MCPHERSON]
JOE BRITT: So this is
a great example.
So at any time, anyone can move
songs around the queue,
and anyone can take control of
the listening experience.
Everyone can see the queue in
real time on their devices.
It's pretty cool that my friends
can now play their
music in my living room.
[APPLAUSE]
JOE BRITT: So that's music on
Nexus Q with multi-room
playback and social streaming.
A great amplifier built right in
with digital output, so you
can hear music on the best
speakers and TV in your home.
And speaking of TV, wouldn't it
be cool if you could bring
all of your movies to
a friend's house?
Well, with Google Play, you're
always carrying your entire
digital library with you.
And as a social streaming
device, Nexus Q lets anyone
connect and start playing
videos from
their phone right away.
Have you guys seen any
movies lately?
MATT HERSHENSON: What do you
guys think about Transformers,
Dark of the Moon?
CHRIS: I hear it's
pretty good.
But I always think, is there
more than meets the eye?
MATT HERSHENSON: (SINGING)
The robots in disguise.
JOE BRITT: Do we have
that movie?
MATT HERSHENSON: I have it
in my library right here.
JOE BRITT: OK, cool.
Let's check it out.
So Matt's going into Play
Movies and TV App
on his Nexus 7.
And all he has to do is
choose the living
room TV and hit Play.
MATT HERSHENSON: I
was watching it
at home last night.
I'm going to start it up here,
and it's going to pick up at
the very same spot where I left
off when I was playing it
at home last night.
Check it out.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
CHRIS: I always liked
Bumblebee.
-Well, he's dead.
MATT HERSHENSON: It's awesome.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
JOE BRITT: OK, cool.
So you just saw how easy it was
for Matt to play a movie
from his collection on my TV.
No messy authentication or
configuration needed.
It just works.
And remember, what's really
cool here is that Matt is
controlling what's happening
from his Android tablet, but
the movie is coming directly
from the cloud.
Now, it's always fun to watch
YouTube videos with friends.
And Nexus Q works great
with YouTube.
Just like with music, you and
your friends can play your
favorite YouTube videos right
on Nexus Q. And again, the
content comes from the cloud.
So Randall's going to go into
the YouTube app and search for
Android in space.
Some of the guys on our team
worked with a student who had
a great idea to send an Android
figurine into space.
So let's take a look at that.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[RADIO COMMUNICATION]
JOE BRITT: So that's
really cool.
But now let's take a look
at another video.
Matt, what would you
like to see?
MATT HERSHENSON: There's this
is cool video of these guys
beatboxing on a Google+
Hangout on
their Galaxy Nexuses.
Let's play that.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
JOE BRITT: Cool.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[BEATBOXING]
-Check this out.
JOE BRITT: So as you can see,
Matt was able to just take
over the TV straight
from YouTube.
No more passing around
a keyboard or laptop.
Everyone is in control.
So that's Nexus Q.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
JOE BRITT: Amazing hardware
with an integrated app.
It streams music, movies, and
TV from Google Play, as well
as YouTube.
And what's really cool is that
it's the world's first ever
social streaming device.
Nexus Q will sell for $299.
It'll be available in
the US to start.
And you'll be able to purchase
it right from Google Play.
You can place a pre-order
starting today, and we'll
begin shipping orders in July.
Thanks, everyone.
And here's Hugo to
wrap things up.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGO BARRA: Thanks, guys.
That was pretty awesome.
Well, we hope you guys liked
what you saw here today.
400 million Android devices,
Jelly Bean, Google Play, Nexus
7, Nexus Q.
Now, the Android ecosystem would
be nothing without our
developer community.
So I wanted to thank you guys
for your incredible support.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGO BARRA: We hope you enjoy
the 26 dedicated Android
sessions plus all the Sandboxes
that we put together
for you here at Google I/O.
There's a lot to see.
And look forward to seeing
you at the party tonight.
Thank you.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Ladies
and gentlemen,
once again, Vic Gundotra.
VIC GUNDOTRA: Hello
again, everybody.
It was exactly one year ago
today, and it was a day that I
don't think I'm ever
going to forget.
You see, it was the eve before
we unveiled Google+, and I was
pretty nervous.
After all, we had no idea how
people were going to react.
It's amazing that tomorrow
morning will be our one-year
anniversary.
Thank you all for your
support for Google+.
And because of your support, we
gain momentum every week.
And we're just more than
a little bit excited.
We really think we're onto
something special.
To give you an example of what
that something is, let's go to
this video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Everyone good to go?
-Good to go.
-I'm good.
-I'm gonna click on
Start Broadcast.
Hi, everybody.
Once again, we're going to have
our virtual star party
working the telescopes today--
-I love science.
I love communicating
and exploring
about space and astronomy.
So when Google+ came out, I
thought, wouldn't it be cool
if we could get a telescope
streaming an image right into
the Hangout?
-We've got Mike Phillips, and
he's in North Carolina.
We've got Gary Gonnella.
What's your view, Gary?
-The Monkey Heads in the
upper part of Orion.
-Before this was impossible.
But now we're getting people
from Mexico, and South
America, and South
Africa, Malaysia.
We're starting to capture
the whole Earth.
Because suddenly, there is a way
we are able to bring all
these people together
and put on a show.
-Oh, too close.
-I think everyone's
ready but Mike.
Oh, I think I see something.
Can you move it a little
down, Mike?
There it is.
Oh, man, look at that.
-Being able to look out into
space gives us context for how
we live in our day-to-day
experience.
It shows us that we're part
of this bigger universe.
-Gary, you've got the
Rosette for me?
-I do.
-I mean for us, I mean for
us, for everyone to see.
Not just me.
-Don't kid us.
It's for you, Fraser.
-It's for me, yeah.
-Now we have Saturn is green.
You guys are just [INAUDIBLE].
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
VIC GUNDOTRA: Sorry you missed
the first part of that video.
But I think it got
the point across.
Because of people like Frank
and Pamela, we now have a
vibrant community of astronomers
on Google+.
Yes, astronomers.
And you know what?
There are Frank and Pamelas
for all other kinds of
subjects too.
From health, to knitting, to
sports, to photography, to
music, even nuclear physics.
Yes, millions of people are
finding ways to connect with
each other, to share
their passions,
to find their community.
And they're doing
it on Google+.
Now Google+ is at the heart of
our efforts to really create a
simpler, more intuitive
experience
for all Google users.
You should think of
it in two parts.
The first is our social
[? spine. ?]
Once you've logged in and
upgraded to Google+, we want
to present you with one seamless
experience, not a
series of disconnected
products.
So far, in just one year, over
250 million people have
upgraded to Google+, with 150
million of those being 30-day
actives, and 50% of that number
signing in every day.
Those daily active users spend
more than an hour with Google.
Now, the other part is our
social destination.
Now that part is growing
quickly.
And it really began with a
base of zero last year,
because we're building a
brand-new community.
There, we're seeing
really impressive
engagement and fast growth.
Active Google+ users are now
spending more than 12 minutes
a day in the stream.
That's up from 9 minutes
just a few months ago.
Now you might be asking, well,
Vic, what comes next?
And the answer there
lies in mobile.
The growth of smartphones
has been spectacular.
It has been a sea change for our
industry, and the same is
true for Google+.
We now have more users engaging
with Google+ from
mobile than from desktop.
Let me repeat that.
We had more people using
Google+ from
mobile than from desktop.
This is a significant
situation and one
we take very seriously.
In fact, if you've been watching
us, over the past
several weeks, you've seen us
upgrade our mobile clients for
iOS and for Android to
really great reviews.
So thank you.
Yet we keep hearing the same
requests from users, which is,
hey, Vic, when are we going
to get a native
tablet version of Google+?
Well, your answer is you're
going to get it today.
[APPLAUSE]
VIC GUNDOTRA: Now, I could spend
an hour talking to you
about this new application.
I believe it's the
best version of
Google+ we've ever designed.
But my trusty friend, Matt, and
I instead are just going
to highlight a few
of the features.
If we switch over to demo--
there we go.
The first thing you'll notice is
a stream that's gorgeous, a
stream that's fast,
fluid, beautiful.
Photos pop.
Text is crisp.
Even actions like +1 and
Comments are not just
prominent, they're playful.
We're also stylizing the stream
in such a way that it
makes it very easy to scan
while still highlighting
what's important.
So for example, photos,
text, videos all have
a distinctive look.
So it's easy to know
what someone is
sharing at a glance.
At the same time, we look for
posts that are becoming very
popular with more engagement.
And we make them bigger, so they
help grab your attention.
This stream just feels great
to use, and I can't wait to
get it into your hands.
Now the second thing I want to
show you is, of course, one of
the foundations of Google+
which is the Hangout
experience.
And Hangouts, as you know, is
live, multi-user video.
But on a tablet, it enables a
kind of intimacy that's not
possible on other devices.
You can really just hold the
tablet in your hand, lean
back, and enjoy your friends'
and family's company.
Now in this case, Matt
is inviting some
people to join him.
On both screens here, you see
the invite experience or the
ringing experience.
It's gorgeous.
You can swipe to answer it just
like a call, or you can
accept the Hangout.
And now, of course, you could
see everyone in the Hangout.
We've muted the audio so that
we don't get feedback.
But you can see, it's typically
what you see in
Hangouts, people just
having fun.
And of course, you
can pin videos.
You can swipe left and right
to see who's in the room.
And my favorite feature,
Google+ Hangouts will
automatically switch video based
on whoever's talking to
really make it feel like
a live conversation.
You can see they're having
lots and lots of fun.
Now there's a lot more other
improvements in the app that
we just don't have time to
show you, things like
brand-new navigation, a new
ribbon bar, a new place to see
notifications, brand-new
profiles that make it fun to
explore other people's
content.
It's just fantastic.
Now, if you're an iPad user,
we've got you covered too.
In fact, everything we've just
shown you is launching on the
iPad as well coming soon.
Let's switch to the iPad.
And you'll note--
so I'll wait till you
get it up-- on
the iPad, it's gorgeous.
You get this beautiful stream.
You get the same immersive
Hangouts.
You get all the new navigation,
the new profiles.
And it looks just gorgeous
on that retina display.
So that's the Google+ tablet
app rolling out for Android
today, available for
the iPad very soon.
What do you think?
[APPLAUSE]
VIC GUNDOTRA: Well, although
we've just updated the Android
smartphone app barely a month
ago, we have an additional
surprise for you.
All those improvements that you
just saw for tablets are
coming to the Android
smartphone
today in Android Play.
It's also available
for your phone.
So enjoy that.
Now we have one more Google+
announcement today.
And it goes back to really why
we started the project in the
first place, to really bring
real-life sharing to software.
Think about the time that you
spend with the people that you
love, your family, your
best friends.
Think about where you spend
that time with them.
It's likely at a barbecue, a
restaurant, a picnic, a wedding.
The common theme here is that
these are all events.
Events have a wonderful way
to bring people together.
They allow you to create and
share cherished moments.
Yet unfortunately, the substance
of a real-world
event is lost online.
Just consider the state of
today's online tools.
Online event tools basically are
glorified web forums that
ask you, are you going?
Yes or no.
They kind of help you
manage who you're
inviting to the party.
But what happens when
the party starts?
Well, what about after
the party?
Today's online tools bail when
you need them the most.
In life, we plan, we party,
we keep in touch.
We think software should make
all of that more awesome
before, during, and
after your event.
That's why today we're so
excited to be announcing
Google+ Events.
Now, for the next few moments,
I'm going to show you how you
can use Google+ Events
before, during, and
after your next party.
Let's start off with before.
Now, perhaps the most important
thing we do is
invite someone.
When you invite someone to your
home, or to a wedding, or
even to your favorite
restaurant, that's a deeply
intimate act.
You're handpicking who's going
to be in the room.
So we think that who you're
inviting should
feel special too.
And so that's why we've designed
a product to offer
lots of ways to send absolutely
beautiful
invitations in something we
call cinemagraphic themes.
I'll show you that
in a moment.
We also understand that you
need to manage the entire
process, and we've built in
great management tools,
including deep integration
with Google Calendar.
Let's just show you.
Matt, here, is going to invite
some friends to a brunch.
Wait till we switch to demo.
So Matt's going to
use the product.
He is going to click on the
Calendar button there
in the Share box.
And he's going to now start
inviting people to a brunch in
Half Moon Bay.
It's a city about 30
miles from here.
It happens to be his hometown.
And he'll fill in some
basic information.
Now he'll choose a theme.
Now here's where it gets
really amazing.
We have over two dozen of
these cinemagraphs,
beautifully animated themes.
You may not be able to see the
subtle animation in the
audience, but some of these
are just amazing.
Lights flicker.
You can see the barbecue.
That's one of my favorites.
And we really professionally
built some amazing ways to
make your guests feel special.
Now, since this is a beach
brunch, why don't you pick a
beach theme?
And he'll go ahead
and set that.
Now, finally, Matt will add
guests whether or not they're
on Google+.
He just adds their emails, and
then he sends the invitation.
Now let's see what it's like
to receive the invitation.
In this case, we're
going to switch.
We're going to pretend to be
Lindsay, one of Matt's
imaginary friends.
Yes, he has lots of imaginary
friends still.
Now, from Lindsay's viewpoint,
she gets this beautiful event
post in the stream.
And when she hovers over that,
it unfolds just like you might
with an invitation you
received in the mail.
Lindsay can check her schedule
right from the post with
Calendar integration.
And she can see that
she's free.
And so she'll say, yes,
that she's going.
Now if you jump over to
Lindsay's calendar, a
brand-new feature in Google
Calendar, first, the social
event has been added.
Matt's photo is in the corner.
And if she clicks on that,
she gets that beautiful
cinemagraph integrated
right in.
Isn't that awesome?
[APPLAUSE]
VIC GUNDOTRA: She can even see
the beautiful faces of her
friends who are going.
All of these small details, we
think, help set the mood for
your event, the right mood
right from the start.
Now finally, we can
click through into
the event page detail.
And there, once again, Lindsay
can pull down on the invite,
get that beautiful experience.
She can see updates
from the host.
She can see photos.
She can see who else is going.
Let's go back to slides.
So we think that the combination
of cinemagraphs,
Calendar integration, those
other things that we showed
you really make it both a
beautiful and a useful way for
you to manage your party.
But that's just before
the event.
Now let's talk about
during the event.
Now, it's no surprise that
during the event,
photos are a big deal.
Just taking a photo causes
people to smile and laugh.
They help us relive the
event when it's over.
But you know what
the problem is.
Today, with the proliferation
of devices and smartphones,
everyone's photos get lost.
They're with all the guests,
and they never,
ever come back together.
So no one can enjoy
them in one spot.
With Google+ Events, we have a
groundbreaking feature, my
favorite feature
of the product.
And it's called Party Mode, and
it fixes those problems.
Once you've enabled Party Mode
on your device, all new photos
automatically get added to
the event in real time.
As more and more guests turn
on Party Mode, all those
photos instantly appear.
In this way, Google+
Events gives your
party a visual pulse.
We've even added a live slide
show that you can show during
the event to make it fun.
Let's show you.
Let's go back to demo.
Matt's obviously in the mood.
His brunch has already
started.
Now, because it's already
started, Android knows that
this is the correct time.
And it sends him this
notification.
Now, at Matt's discretion, he
can choose with one click to
take that first photo and
turn on Party Mode.
Go ahead, Matt.
Take your picture.
All right, very good.
Now, if you note at the top,
the green icon stays there.
So you always know when
Party Mode is on.
And as guests turn this on, they
can control the settings
right there in Notifications.
Let's go back to the Events
landing page.
Now, on the Events landing page,
you get to see all the
photos stream in.
People who are at the event who
are taking pictures, they
will just show up right here.
I guess you can see the brunch
is going on over there.
And they just stream
in real time.
That's a lot of fun to just
watch as it happens.
Now, in addition to having
this view, we built in
a slide show view.
So, Matt, if you go to the top
there, it says, play the live
slide show.
And if you click during the
event, we'll go to an
absolutely gorgeous full-screen
light box.
And your guests' photos will
appear instantly after they've
taken those pictures.
Isn't that just great?
[APPLAUSE]
VIC GUNDOTRA: We've
talked about
before, during, and after.
Let's switch back to slides,
and let's talk
about after the event.
After the event, what happens
when the guests go home?
Well, we reminisce about the
event, we might think of
something that was very special,
and we try to hold on
to those memories.
Because getting everyone's
photos and videos, we've given
up on that.
Well, not anymore.
As you saw with Party Mode,
Google+ will send emails to
all your guests and ask them to
upload photos they may have
taken from other DSLRs.
And then we'll do something
amazing.
We'll put all of them in one
place in chronological order.
Let me show you.
Let's show what the Events
page looks like.
Now, one of our teammates, Dave,
recently got married.
And like any good engineer, he
decided to test Events at his
own wedding.
Now what you're looking at
is really his wedding.
So thank you, Dave,
for doing this.
Let's skip the top there
for a second, and
let's look at this.
What you're seeing here--
Matt, if you just
scroll down--
is literally all the photos from
all the guests who had
Party Mode turned on.
And if Matt moves over any one
of those photos, in the bottom
right-hand corner, you can see
the pictures of the guests who
contributed that photograph.
We automatically put them
in chronological order.
So from the ceremony to the
reception, you can see the
event from different
perspectives.
It's the first time you've been
able to go do this in a
beautiful way.
Now if you go all the way to the
top of the stream there,
we also do something else
that's pretty cool.
We analyze all the photos, and
we look at the photos that got
the most engagement, either
comments or +1.
And there, at Events Highlights
at the top, we give
you the most popular photos.
So, Matt, if you click on that
top one, you can see that was
the photo that got the most
engagement from his wedding,
the most engagement
from his guests.
Absolutely gorgeous.
Now in addition, if there was
a photo of you and you are
tagged in a photo, your
photos would be there
right at the top.
Now, what if you have a friend
and you just want to see
photos that they took?
Well, you can see the different
photographers who
had Party Mode turned on
and who contributed.
In this case, Matt clicked
on Denise.
And now he's seeing
all of the photos
coming just from Denise.
When you consider what Google+
Events does for before,
during, and after an event, it
really speaks to what we're
trying to do with
Google overall.
SERGEY BRIN: Hey, Vic.
VIC GUNDOTRA: Sergey.
SERGEY BRIN: I've got a really
cool event for you.
[APPLAUSE]
SERGEY BRIN: How you doing?
VIC GUNDOTRA: Guys, we're going
to do something pretty
magical here.
And we have a special
surprise for you.
SERGEY BRIN: We've
got something
pretty special for you.
It's a little bit
time-sensitive, so I apologize
for interrupting.
We've seen some really
compelling demos here.
They were slick, they
were robust.
This is going to be
nothing like that.
This can go wrong in about
500 different ways.
So tell me now, who wants
to see a demo of Glass?
[APPLAUSE]
SERGEY BRIN: So we've been
really excited to test it for
a few months.
The unit I actually really
want to show
you, I lent to a friend.
And he's going to be
here momentarily.
My friend's JT.
He does a lot of skiing, base
jumping, wingsuiting, all
sorts of crazy things.
And he's actually
pretty close by.
He's just about a mile
overhead right
now with his buddies.
They have a few Glass units.
If you guys can maybe afford to
wait that couple minutes--
[APPLAUSE]
SERGEY BRIN: --maybe they'll
bring them down.
We're about to get into a
Hangout here with JT.
Hey, JT, JT, can you hear me?
JT: Yes.
SERGEY BRIN: Hello, hello.
We might have a few
technical issues.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JT: Can you hear me?
SERGEY BRIN: Yeah, yeah.
Hey, we're just down
here in Moscone.
I've got a few thousand
people here.
I was hoping to maybe get that
unit I lent you down here.
And I thought maybe you guys
could show us a fun time on
the way down.
JT: Yeah, if you can hear
me down there, I've been
listening to your speech
through the Hangout.
It's pretty cool.
SERGEY BRIN: Cool, cool.
I see you and friends are
[? plenty ?] close by there.
Any chance we can get a little
view out the window?
JT: Heck, yeah.
Yeah, it's beautiful up here.
We had a visual on Moscone
a minute ago.
SERGEY BRIN: This is a
Hangout from Glass.
JT: I'm gonna come in a little
closer, and I think we're
going to get you that device
pretty quickly actually.
SERGEY BRIN: I see the roof
of Moscone there.
So if you guys can be safe,
but get it down here in a
hurry for us, we'd love
to watch that.
JT: OK, yeah, you'll
have to stand by.
We've got our wingsuits, so
we've got a pretty good range.
It's kind of interesting.
People have watched us fly
many times before.
But I don't think that the
world's ever tagged along live
for a ride.
Nobody really knows the
outcome of this jump.
We're feeling really
confident about it.
How you feeling, Pete?
SERGEY BRIN: Well, we're
all rooting for you.
What do you guys think?
Should they go for it?
[APPLAUSE]
SERGEY BRIN: Oh, let's do it.
JT: We're not in position
yet, huh, Julian?
About one minute, Sergey.
Maybe you've got to entertain
the crowd a little.
SERGEY BRIN: Well, let's
look at the view down.
That looks like a
long way down.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah,
turn it sideways.
JT: Oh yeah, there's
the ballpark.
MALE SPEAKER: This is
good stuff here.
JT: Yeah, Moscone Center.
I've got a visual on you.
SERGEY BRIN: So this is one of
the things as we've been
experimenting with Glass, just
the ability to really share.
And we've posted
some pictures.
But as we start to experiment,
being able to share what
you're seeing live is
really amazing.
And we don't know what's
going to happen here.
These guys are all
really good.
They're trained.
And I have great confidence.
But this is a demo that--
all right.
Doors open.
Happy flight.
MALE SPEAKER: You know what?
We can jump.
MALE SPEAKER: Let's do it.
JT: It's gonna be beautiful.
Yeah, look at that.
Hello, San Francisco.
[CHEERS]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SERGEY BRIN: I'm on pins
and needles right now.
JT: Everybody's super happy?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: Nice and
close in there.
SERGEY BRIN: They've got to get
the right place, so they
can hit the roof.
I'm going to take a
few pictures to
record this for posterity.
And they're off, yeah.
And they're flying.
Look at that.
You can see Moscone
right below there.
Live Hangout through
Google Glass.
We've got four skydivers, and
they're under canopy.
Chutes are open.
[APPLAUSE]
SERGEY BRIN: OK, where's Vic?
Vic, hey, look.
This is a Hangout on Air.
[LAUGHTER]
SERGEY BRIN: So it's a little
bit tricky landing on a
building, as you
might imagine.
I don't know if you ever tried
this kind of thing before.
But you can see all their
perspectives now.
They're going to have to line
up one after another to get
down to the roof here.
It's a pretty big roof actually,
which is great for
their landing.
And you can see there's a
little yellow arrow that
they're aiming for.
It's pretty exciting.
Hopefully, they land it.
And they're coming in.
First one's coming in.
All right.
[APPLAUSE]
SERGEY BRIN: So how
you, folks?
Thank you.
So the roof is a little
bit big there.
So it would take a while to
run down the length of it.
So we got actually a few bikers
up there for this
eventuality.
We got them wearing Glass too.
And there's our little
package.
Let's see if we can get
it here in a hurry.
Here we go.
First person [INAUDIBLE]
Glass.
Here are the bikers.
Yeah, whoo hoo.
Here they come down.
And there's only one good way
down the side of a building.
It's pretty high up there
if you haven't
been up there before.
Don't try this at home, kids.
These are trained
professionals.
MALE SPEAKER: All right, now
we gotta get down there.
Want to unplug me?
SERGEY BRIN: Here
they're going.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
No, no, no, we're
on the third--
OK.
Close call.
Sorry about that.
So this is pretty wild.
I've never seen that
perspective before.
And I'm really looking
forward to this.
We got a couple more bikes.
It's a little bit
of a long way.
I apologize.
Don't run anybody over.
Oh, oh.
All right.
Please stay in your
seats, folks.
Don't get into the aisles.
Please keep the aisles clear.
Here they come up.
Yeah, whoo hoo.
Yeah, that was awesome, man.
That was pretty amazing.
A big round of applause
for our bikers.
[APPLAUSE]
SERGEY BRIN: Thought I'd get a
little picture of you there
with my Glass.
Thank you, guys.
Some of our athletes who are
performers, I just wanted to
give them another big
round of applause.
We've got the rappelers
in the back.
Let's sign them up.
And the skydivers should be
chasing close behind them.
Thank you, guys, so much.
That was amazing.
Thanks, guys.
Well, come on up, guys.
You're already here.
Come on up.
Take a bow.
These are the rappelers, all the
bikers you saw up there.
And there's the skydiving crew
coming down the aisle.
Hey, JT.
JT: Hey, Sergey.
SERGEY BRIN: That was amazing.
Hey, thank you, guys.
We were worried about you.
That was awesome.
Thank you all so much.
Now maybe we should tell you
a little bit about Glass.
All right, guys, have fun.
You can meet them.
They'll be out and around if
you want to chat with them.
Thank you so much.
Now here's what--
no, no, this is the wrong one.
Wait.
We're gonna have to--
I think we're going to
have to do it again.
JT: I'd be happy to.
SERGEY BRIN: All right.
We'll find a time.
We actually might find a time.
If you want to see behind the
scenes and maybe catch some of
that activity through Hangout,
tune in tomorrow.
But now I just want to tell you
a bit about how we made
that happen and why we're
so excited about Glass.
And to tell you that, I have
Babak and Isabelle.
Please welcome them aboard.
BABAK PARVIZ: Good morning.
So what can I say?
Awesome.
I wanted to take a minute and
tell you what was the device
that enabled this beautiful
demonstration
that we just saw.
The devices that we used were
Google Glass prototypes, and
quite similar, actually,
to what I'm
wearing at the moment.
This device includes--
which by the way, is not that
that you see behind me,
slightly different--
has a display, so I can see
visual information right now,
images, video.
It has a camera to capture
picture and video.
So it has a pretty powerful
processor to process
information and a lot of memory
to store information.
In order to interact with this
device, you have a touch pad
on the side.
You also have a little
button here.
So I'd like to take a picture
of you right now,
which I just did.
We have microphones, so we can
collect audio information.
We also have a small speaker,
so I can receive audio
information.
The device also has a
number of sensors.
So we have gyroscopes,
accelerometers, and a compass.
So it's aware of its location
with respect to my body and is
also aware of its location in
the broader physical world.
And lastly and very importantly,
it has multiple
radios for data communication.
To give you a bit about the
history of our group, we
started about two, two and a
half years ago to incorporate
this much technology into a
very small form factor.
And the picture that you see
behind me, this is a good
friend of mine, one of the
pioneers of wearable computing
and one of our team members.
This is Thad Starner.
We had to hack things
together--
we're sort of a hacky,
informal group--
to get the technology on
people's bodies to make it
wearable and test
out the ideas.
So we started from this point
two, two and a half years ago.
And through a lot of hard
work by our team, and
experimentation, we made
progress and reduced the form
factor to what you see here.
Now I would like to invite the
lead designer, Isabelle, to
talk about some of the design
philosophy that has gone into
this device.
ISABELLE OLSSON: Thank you.
So we created Glass so that
you can interact with the
virtual world without
distracting you
from the real world.
And one clear example of this is
that we decided to actually
position the display
above your eye.
And Glass as a whole is designed
to be close to your
senses, but not blocking them.
And this picture shows so
clearly how we don't want
technology to get in the way.
The baby looks into
the Mom's eyes.
They connect.
And while doing that, she can
capture this beautiful moment
without any distractions.
And whether it's with family or
friends, we want to empower
people to use technology
naturally, like in this moment
of celebration.
So we wanted to pack all this
amazing technology into this
product to let you do amazing
things with it.
But that's also a slight
conflict, through that if this
is not ridiculously light, it
doesn't belong on your face.
And we didn't only want to make
it physically light, but
also visually light.
We don't want to compete too
much with the user's own
individuality, so no superfluous
detailing.
And we really tried to reduce
it to its core essence.
And one of the results of this
is that our latest prototype
weighs less on your nose
than many sunglasses.
So when it really dawned on me
that we were onto something
was when I started seeing people
in our team posting
pictures on Google+ while
running with it.
And if it's not super
comfortable and super sturdy,
how would you be able to show
off your serve like this?
This is Max on our team.
He wanted to brag
a little bit.
But sometimes you want to do
less conventional sports, like
jumping into ball pits.
So we want Glass to work for
many people and most
situations.
And realizing that, we needed
to create a scalable design.
We decided to put all the
components off to one side,
creating an asymmetrical design,
but that's balanced.
And what this allows us to do
is to design different form
factors for the frames.
And this is something we're
experimenting a lot with.
And here you can see Mike, Liza,
and Maddie wearing their
favorite styles.
BABAK PARVIZ: So we have this
incredibly powerful platform,
lots of capability integrated
into a very small
form factor, wearable.
And you might be wondering, what
is the impetus for our
team to embark on this journey
to build this system?
And what are the uses that
we envision for this?
What's the reason for people
actually to put
this on their head?
Broadly speaking, we have two
broad regions of aspiration.
The first one has to do with
communicating through images.
And the second one with very
rapid access to information.
If you think about actually
how we connect to people
today, we might have
a conversation
or we may call them.
So there's an audio way of
connecting to others.
We may send them an SMS.
We may send them an email.
We may send them a letter.
So we use letters of alphabet
or writing to convey our
emotions to other people of
how we feel at that very
moment or at any given
point in time.
And we believe, actually,
communication with images and
access to devices that empower
people to communicate with
images in new ways are truly
revolutionary and may actually
enable people to connect
in new and
potentially better ways.
Now, wearing a glass has certain
unique aspects to it.
For example, when you have a
companion camera that's always
with you, you can catch fleeting
moments in your life
that otherwise would
be always lost.
So this is an example
of a group member
walking on the beach.
I'm sure many of you
in the audience
like myself are parents.
And many, many times, you've
asked and wished that, oh, I
wish I had a camera with me
right now to capture this
unique moment with my family.
When you have Glass, you can
actually capture those moments
and have those memories forever
recorded for you.
This is pretty important,
actually, when we
enable such a thing.
Another unique aspect of Glass
is that this is genuinely the
first-person point of view
through your eyes
as you see the world.
This is one of our team members
finishing a race.
And you can see actually how it
felt at that very moment,
basically going through
a very long run.
Or you might have a moment of
respite, and this is how the
world looked to you as you were
enjoying a few seconds of
break through your busy day.
And going back to the theme of
family, you can actually
record how your life looked
like with your loved ones
through the first person
point of view.
Quite important, I think,
and it could
be very, very powerful.
And honestly, there are some
moments that you may not want
to record forever, but
sometimes it happens.
So this is--
oh, yeah.
This is Will.
He's sitting right here.
He's one of our team members,
and he's just practicing pool.
So these things can
also happen.
ISABELLE OLSSON: So you've seen
all these unique moments
that our team members have
captured just using the device
for a couple of months.
So all this footage is from our
team using Glass, which is
pretty incredible.
But what really excites me about
this is not only the
unique perspective from your
point of view, but how easy
and seamless it is to share.
And I think this encouraged
people to do
new things with it.
We just saw how it is to
jump out of a plane.
And you can experience these
moments where you feel like
you're there.
And you don't actually
even need a Glass
device to do that.
So here is, for example,
learning new things.
This is Beau going through, step
by step, how to create
very tasty dumplings.
And I think there is something
really powerful about this.
And sometimes it's all about
feeling like you're there.
This stream of pictures
showed up.
And I was sitting at my desk,
a little bit bored,
and this comes up.
And I had this visceral reaction
that I got so much
anxiety all of a sudden.
I could totally relate to
Stephen sitting in this chair.
And these pictures continuously
showed up in real time.
And I was also able to write
little comments and say, dude,
it's all going to be OK.
And sometimes it's not
about grand things.
Sometimes it's only about
communicating an emotion or in
a situation.
And this is Mike walking on
the street in New York and
looking for some empathy from
his friends in California.
BABAK PARVIZ: So the second main
aspiration that we have
for Glass is to enable
people to access
information very quickly.
Nowadays, if you're looking for
answers to your questions,
you may do a variety
of things.
You may seek a friend and
ask them, what is the
answer to my question?
You may go to the library
and go through books.
But more likely than not, you
will reach to your pocket,
take out the cell phone, unlock
it, and do a search.
And you get some amazing
results back, actually.
We saw some incredible
technology just now
demonstrated by Android.
And what we aspire to
do is to make that
even much, much faster.
And some day, we would like to
make this so fast that you
don't feel that you have a
question, you have to go seek
the knowledge somewhere, bring
it back, and analyze it.
We would like it to be so
fast that you feel you
know it that fast.
And that day may not be today.
That day may not be tomorrow.
But at least that's
our aspiration.
And we would like to be able
to empower people to access
information very,
very quickly.
And in practice, basically, they
feel more knowledgeable
about certain topics.
Now, there are different types
of information that you might
have in front of you.
So for example, you could
be in a place.
You would like to have
information about this place
without disconnecting from your
physical environment.
You might also want
to know how to
navigate to the next place.
There's a lot of interesting
information
actually in this scene.
Or you may be biking,
and you want to know
how fast you're going.
Obviously, you don't want to
disengage from the physical
world, go to the computing
world, and come back.
You want to remain engaged with
the physical world in a
very unhindered way and still
get the information that you
would like to have.
Another thing that may come
up is that you may face an
entirely new and unexpected
situation.
This is a picture from a friend
of mine, [INAUDIBLE].
He's a team member, and he was
sent to the market by his wife
to do some shopping.
And you just are baffled
at what you're seeing.
And you would like to have
information right at that very
moment in front of you without
disengaging from
the physical world.
So we are very excited about
this possibility.
And I am particularly excited
to present this to you.
Because the crowd here, the
people who are watching are
some of the smartest developers
in the world.
And I think you would actually,
hopefully, help us
to figure out what kind of
information we should bring
here and put in front
of people's eyes.
The possibilities are
just incredible.
ISABELLE OLSSON: So we shared
a little bit about our
perceptive on Glass, and from
our team, and pictures, and
videos, and also some of the
incredible things you can do.
But what really sums it up
for me is this video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-This is baby June.
Our family is in France.
So for us, it's really important
to show them how
she's growing, how
she's changing.
With babies, it's really hard
to grab the right moments.
A smile just lasts for a few
seconds, and that's all.
When you use a big camera,
she gets really
focused on the camera.
She's smiles at faces,
not at devices.
Every day, we try to go
out for a little walk.
June really loves being
in the stroller.
Everything is new for her.
So we really like to take
funny pictures of her.
I think she enjoyed it.
-Hey, salud.
-Bon jour, [? uncle. ?]
How are you?
-I'm good, but I
miss you guys.
-We have these little American
glasses that
she likes to wear.
It's kind of amazing for us
French to have this little
American girl at home.
-Au revoir, [INAUDIBLE].
[BABY CRYING]
-Oh, no.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
SERGEY BRIN: Thank you,
guys, very much.
And I'm so jazzed that that
actually worked, the whole
bit, [? the air ?] ship,
everything, and this
presentation.
I wasn't really expecting
it to.
But I wanted to tell you, well,
you've seen a whole
bunch of stuff.
I'm personally really excited
about Glass in
my day-to-day usage.
I've had moments with
family like that.
And there are all kinds
of things this
can capture and share.
But obviously, capturing images,
videos, even sharing
video, that's only a part
of what a wearable
computer can do.
And we've highlighted a few
other little things here.
But why are we showing
you basically
this kind of utility?
And there are basically
three reasons.
The first is because we've
just found it incredibly
compelling since we made
these and started using
them out and about.
We've just found that
to be amazing.
The second is it's actually one
of the things we can show
you, because you all can't
experience what it's like to
have all this information
available right
here just like that.
And so there are other kinds of
things that we use it for.
But it's hard to demonstrate.
I guess you could put one glass
on top of another glass,
and then you'd see what
we experience.
But that might be awkward.
So you haven't had a chance
to experience it.
And third, we're a pretty
small team.
And we've only had so much time
to try various kinds of
functionality.
And in fact, every day, we've
been getting great ideas from
inside, from outside, from
all around the world.
And that's why we really want
to involve all of you.
This developer community is
going to be key to us.
And that's why today, I'd like
to announce the Google Glass
Explorer Edition.
It's going to be something that
we'd like to get in the
hands of people who are really
passionate about it, who want
to be among the earliest
to get this device.
This is not going to be a
consumer device in a sense.
It's going to be rough
around the edges.
You have to want to be
on the bleeding edge.
And that's what this is
really designed for.
[APPLAUSE]
SERGEY BRIN: So it's only
available for pre-order here
at I/O. I apologize for
this right now.
It's only for US-based
I/O attendees.
It's just a bunch of regulatory
stuff that we have
to get through.
And so we'll try to broaden
the base over time.
We're trying to get it out to
people as early as we can, so
we can get that feedback.
It will be $1,500.
We plan on shipping to
you early next year.
I know a lot of the things we
discussed here are like, you
can get in them,
[? do your whatnot. ?]
This is a really
new technology.
And we really want to get all
of you to help shape it.
And that's why we really want
to get it out into the hands
of passionate people as
early as possible.
So by the way, you
can get that.
There's going to be
a booth set up.
It's just going to be outside
on your right.
And you can stop by there
anytime today or tomorrow
during the conference.
Right now, we're only accepting
orders at the
conference.
So this is not, as I said,
a mass consumer order.
And I have some clean
up I have to do.
So I apologize also.
I interrupted Vic's
presentation.
So what I'm going to do is,
first of all, I want to thank
Isabelle and Babak so much
for presenting up here.
And another round of applause
for all the people who brought
this together.
And please, let's see.
Is Vic ready?
Vic, I'm so sorry.
But thank you all very much.
We're going to see you around
the conference.
See you around the booths.
VIC GUNDOTRA: Thank you.
Of all the things when I woke
up this morning I wasn't
expecting was that I was going
to have a Taylor Swift moment.
Thanks, Sergey.
Larry, our other co-founder,
has a very
famous saying at Google.
He says, you should have a
healthy disrespect for the
impossible.
And I think what Sergey
just showed you is
an example of that.
When your boss comes to you and
says, hey, we're going to
jump out of an airplane, we're
going to land on the roof of
Moscone, and then we're going
to bike it in, you must be
working at Google.
It was really exciting to see
something that magical.
Let me just wrap up on Events,
and I've got some final
announcements to make.
In fact, the best way to wrap up
on Events is let's just go
to that video.
And I'll make a final
comment after that.
Let's play the video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
VIC GUNDOTRA: When you think
about what we're really trying
to do with Google+ Events for
before, during, and after, it
really speaks to what
we're trying to
do with Google overall.
The best thing is for computers
to have your back.
And then you don't have
to worry about them.
You can focus on what makes
people the happiest, on
living, and on loving,
and not messing
with annoying computers.
With Google+ Events, all you
have to do is show up at your
event, hang out with your
friends, take some photos.
And we think that's a plus.
So we're super excited.
Now, we thought the best way to
kick Google+ Events off is
to have our first official
event tonight, and you're
going to be invited.
That event tonight is an
after-hours party, and that
will become the first official
Google+ Event.
We have Train and Paul Oakenfold
available tonight.
It's gonna be fun, lots
of food, lots of other
entertainment.
I've just got to ask for you,
please download the new
Android version available in
Google Play later today.
That version will have all
the Events integration.
And you'll be able to
turn on Party Mode.
I'm going to go backstage in a
few minutes and send all of
you invites.
And so expect an
invite from me.
We'll see how many contributing
photographers we
can get tonight at the party.
One more thing.
That's right.
Hugo, can you join me onstage?
Thank you, Hugo.
I think you have some exciting
news for these folks.
HUGO BARRA: I do indeed.
Well, because you guys are our
most dedicated developers, we
think it's really important
for you to be able to
experiment early with all the
stuff you saw here today, all
of your devices in your media
working together.
So we've put together for you
an Android developer pack.
All 6,000 of you are going to
be walking away today with a
brand-new Galaxy Nexus
phone, and a
brand-new Nexus 7 tablet.
You're going to get the latest
OTA of the Jelly Bean preview
version a couple of hours
after you power them on.
Shall I keep going?
VIC GUNDOTRA: One more.
HUGO BARRA: OK.
Well, you're also going to be
the very first ones to get
your hands on a shiny,
new Nexus Q.
VIC GUNDOTRA: So thank
you to the generosity
of the Android team.
Thank you all for
your support.
Please don't run out, and
get these devices.
They will be available today
at 4:00 PM onwards on the
ground floor at gear pick-up.
You must have both your badge
and an ID with you.
So please, if you're standing
in line, make sure you have
your ID with you, and you
can pick them up.
Once again, thank you.
We'll see all of you tonight
at the after party.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Jumpers in five, four,
three, two, one.
-Copy that.
Jumpers [INAUDIBLE].
[MUSIC - "QUIET LITTLE VOICES"
BY WE WERE PROMISED JETPACKS]
-This is awesome.
[MUSIC - "QUIET LITTLE VOICES"
BY WE WERE PROMISED JETPACKS]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]